hey guys quick note my brand new book
the authoritarian moment is out
this week go pick up a copy today i
think it's really important
it's about how all of the major
institutions of american society have
now been
taken over and weaponized by the left
against dissent
it's not just about how they did it it's
about how we take those institutions
back
check out the link in the description
below and get a copy of the
authoritarian moment
alrighty well yesterday also featured
the beginning of the january 6th
commission the long-awaited january 6th
commission
and everybody on all sides basically
acknowledges that this
is political what i mean by that is that
we're not uncovering any new information
and yesterday i didn't uncover any new
information we had a bunch of capital
police officers the police are good
again
that's exciting i mean honestly i'm glad
about this the left has decided that the
cops are good again
as long as the cops are being assaulted
by people who are purportedly right-wing
if the cops are being assaulted by black
lives matter protesters
literally by the hundreds if that is
happening across an entire summer the
cops are all systemically racist and bad
and kind of have it coming
if however the cops are assaulted by a
bunch of right-wing droogs
then the cops are good again which is
really exciting news
now the generous commission is not
designed to actually elicit new
information
all it's designed to do is focus in on
how bad january 6th was
and what the left is seeking to
accomplish via this i understand you
know i understand what democrats are
doing they are trying to keep january
6th front and center they are trying to
smear
everybody who is a conservative bent
with january 6 by saying that they're
okay with it
or that it was fine or that they were
they voted for trump and therefore
they're responsible for it
i think that liz cheney and adam
kinzinger i think the reason they're
doing this is because
they believe that trump needs to be
purged from the party and so if they
somehow go along with this commission
this will separate republicans off from
from not understanding
that in the reactionary way our politics
works is precisely the opposite
that the more time you spend talking
about trump the more people on the right
are going to glum
on to trump no matter his uh his various
heresies
in any case the the commission
hearing yesterday was not particularly
newsworthy it just wasn't i'm sorry it's
not news when people talk about things
that we've known for months
it's not news when when you explain
what you felt well a video that we've
already seen was happening
there's nothing new there and yet it was
treated with blanket wall-to-wall
coverage
again at least the benghazi hearings
were an attempt to get hillary clinton
to testify she's a major political
figure she's the secretary of state
she could talk to policy and those are
actually at least somewhat newsworthy
these hearings i just don't understand
what the point is are we uncovering
anything new
talking to police officers about their
feelings well
i am very sympathetic to the feelings of
the police officers i just don't
understand what exactly
is new here and what it really is a
stage for democrats to grandstand
so liz cheney led this thing off she
said you know
we should really be taking this
seriously because do we really hate our
political adversaries more than we love
our country
again no but the question is do
democrats
meaning a little perspective here is
necessary january 6
was really ugly the stuff that donald
trump said between november 4th and
january 6th about the election
was almost entirely not true
with that said i'm not seeing a lot of
love coming from the democratic side
of the aisle for republicans when this
entire commission is almost overtly
designed
to malign the entire republican party as
complicit in january 6.
here's liz cheney going along with that
the question for every one of us
who serves in congress for every elected
official across this great nation
indeed for every american is this
will we adhere to the rule of law
will we respect the rulings of our
courts
will we preserve the peaceful transition
of power
or will we be so blinded by partisanship
that we throw away
the miracle of america i i have a
question um
when was the miracle of america thrown
away vice president pence presided over
the certification of the election
the idiots who ran into the capitol
building have all been arrested they're
going to jail
when i went up by the way whenever i see
the media do this routine about how this
is the worst attack on the capital since
uh the capital was bombed a few times
during the 60s like the senate building
was bombed during the 60s
so uh i have some questions i have some
questions
adam schiff who if you wanted to make
this
yeah if you wanted this commission be
taken seriously you would not put the
clown that is adam chef on stage adam
chef is a clown he's a clown who
pitched a pump tent outside of the
outside of the green room of cnn and
left it there for four years proclaiming
that just around the corner lurked all
of the information about donald trump's
russian clue
[Music]
and now he's out there trying to
proclaim that january 6
was the worst thing that has ever
happened to the country and um and
ginning up some tears for the purpose
there's a lot of crying yesterday
in this commission hearing and i got to
say i'm pretty consistent on this i'm
not a big fan of politicians crying i
just don't think that it's
it's a thing i i don't think that but
that's because i don't think politics is
is generally a place for performative
empathy
i think politics is a solution driven
business or should be i'm not seeing a
lot of solutions i am seeing a lot of
emotion
and if we're so driven by bigotry and
hate that we attack our fellow citizens
as traitors
if they're born another country or they
don't look like us
and
and god help us but
i have faith
because of folks like you acting yeah
they get the john lovett
sorry i i'm sorry i don't believe
politicians generally speaking right or
left when they do this routine
and i certainly don't believe adam
schiff who i think is a congenital liar
so i i
no i don't i don't buy it i'm sorry i
don't buy the emotion
there i don't i mean you've had every
opportunity to to figure out what you're
going to say and what you come up with
is is that
all right okay so then we had a bunch of
capital police officers describing the
events
uh in very colorful ways and listen i'm
not going to doubt the accounts of the
police officers they did say
one of the police officers said
something that wasn't true said that
brian sicknick was killed
on site that that of course is not true
but i'm not going to doubt the
experience of police officers who
got beaten up trying to defend the
capitol building
but again i will note the democrats are
very sympathetic toward a particular
type of police officer depending on who
does the beating
i'm sympathetic to these police officers
because i'm sympathetic to all police
officers
trying to stop criminality but these
police officers got fairly political
yesterday and i think there's a reason
the democrats uh were very happy to to
call them
to the to testify here's capital police
officer michael fanon yesterday
what makes the struggle harder and more
painful
is to know so many of my fellow citizens
including so many of the people i put my
life
at risk to defend are downplaying or
outright denying
what happened i feel like i went to hell
and back to protect them
and the people in this room
but too many are now telling me that
hell doesn't exist
or that hell actually wasn't that bad
the indifference shown to my colleagues
is disgraceful okay so that makes for a
good tv
i'm wondering what the indifference is
like really who's totally different
about january 6th
are there lots of people who are
indifferent about it or are there people
who are saying january 6 was horrifying
and terrible and the people who are the
criminals should go to jail and also
that riot which it was is is no
different
in in content than the riots of blm over
the summer
and treating it as some sort of radical
outlier as opposed to
another act of criminal activity is
blowing this thing out of political
proportion
right for for political purposes and i
don't blame him for for feeling angry
about this sort of stuff
but i i am going to say that i think the
democrats are putting this thing
together for a reason and i think that
cnn is getting what they want out of it
obviously
capital police officer daniel hodges
then described the events as well again
i'm fine with all these people
testifying i'm just wondering when we
get
the the testimony of all the police
officers i mean i know police officers
who were literally hit with bricks
during the blm riots not one of them
will have their face shown on tv by any
of these networks
one count approached protester a black
man was backpedaling away from a white
man at a trump-labeled face mask
who was closely following him with an
outstretched arm
myself and my colleague first arrived
and physically separated the two
but a crowd of donald trump's people had
gathered they attempted to debate the
counter protester into attacking
shouting insults such as your mother's a
and accusing of hiding behind the cops
cut off from our leadership which is at
the front of our formation
we huddled up and assessed threats
surrounding us
one man tried and failed to build a
rapport with me shouting are you my
brother
another takes a different attack
shouting you will die on your knees
yeah i mean that's ugly and horrifying
and worthy of
worthy of remembering is it a
transformative moment in american
politics
i'm not sure why why precisely it should
be considering again the goals of the
protesters
not protesters the goals of the criminal
rioters were not met
in fact they were completely rejected
and those people are going to end up in
jail and then you had police officers
who are drawing political conclusions
you have capital police officer harry
dunn
who called trump a hitman said that
trump was a hitman now um
again testifying outside the area of
expertise i think would be would be
the best way to put this what i asked
from you all
is to get to the bottom of what happened
and that includes like
i echoed the sentiments of all the other
officers sitting here
i use an analogy to describe
what i want as a hit man if a hit man
is hired and he kills somebody the
hitman goes to jail
but not only does the hitman go to jail
but the person who hired them does
there was an attack carried out on
january 6
and a hit man sent them i want you to
get to the bottom of that
okay so trump apparently sent these
people right
now now we are beyond the scope of what
these officers know
or have an ability to know of course but
that's not the point the point is what
can they say on tv and because they're
police officers
you're supposed to just take at face
value their political analysis i'm
willing to face value their experiences
that day
obviously i have no reason to doubt it
it's on tape
also i generally trust police officers
when they testify about what they have
experienced but
i don't see that they have any specific
credibility when it comes to
how things went down regarding the
activities of the white house or whether
trump was somehow organizing with the
people who invaded the capitol building
but again this was the real point of the
january 6 commission in the first place
capital police
officer aquila aquilino ganel did the
same thing he said trump created this
monstrosity
you hear former president trump
say quote it was a loving crowd
there was a lot of love in the crowd how
does that make you feel
it's upsetting is a pathetic
excuse for his behavior for something
that
he himself helped to create this
monstrosity
i'm still recovering from those hugs and
kisses
that day that he claimed that so many
riders terrorists were
assaulting us that day if that was hugs
and kisses then
we should all go to his house and do the
same thing to him
oh great that's it that that's yes
excellent
all right meanwhile by the way harry
done that the the second to last officer
that we discussed a moment ago
uh he actually suggested that because
people mistreated him this is all of
america
this is political guys if it was
supposed to be not political
it was just supposed to be about
uncovering the truth you wouldn't be
asking questions like how did it make
you feel
how did it make you feel is not a
question that elicits truth it's a
question that elicits a subjective
perception that's fine well let's not
pretend this is a fact-finding operation
because it isn't
one woman in a pink mega shirt yelled
you hear that guys
this voted for joe biden
then the crowd perhaps around 20 people
joined in screaming boom
the fact that we had uh our race
attacked and just
because of the way we look you know
to answer your question frankly i guess
it is america
it shouldn't be but i guess that's the
way
that things are it is america okay or or
maybe it's not
maybe it's not you wonder why a lot of
republicans didn't want to go along with
this because they knew that this is what
it was going to be
they knew that this was going to be a
bunch of conclusory
non-evidenced based accusations against
america ripped more broadly
and again the the high cynicism of
democrats
turning into big cop supporters
depending on who exactly is being
targeted
by the police is quite fascinating did
you know that every single like
creates one additional leftist tier that
is just science